>> A LAWYER FOR ALEX JONES'
INFOWARS ADMITTING THAT ALEX
JONES KNEW SANDY HOOK WAS REAL.
>> THE LAWYER REPRESENTING SOME
OF THESE FAMILIES WHO LOST THEIR
CHILDREN, LOVED ONES THAT DAY IS
ASKING THE JURY TO SEND A
MESSAGE WITH HOW MUCH MONEY THEY
SHOULD BE REWARDED.
THEY BROUGHT TO THE STAND A
WOMAN HIRED BY INFOWARS TWO
WEEKS BEFORE THE TRIAL.
HER JOB TO REPRESENT THE COMPANY
AT THE TRIAL.
PROSECUTORS TRYING TO SHOW THAT
JONES PROFITED IMMENSELY OFF HIS
LIES AND MADE MONEY HAND OVER
FIST AFTER CALLING THE MASSACRE
A HOAX.
ALEX JONES BACK IN COURT THIS
WEEK, A CONNECTICUT JURY IS
DETERMINING HOW MUCH MONEY JONES
AND HIS COMPANY, FREE SPEECH
SYSTEMS MUST PAY IN DAMAGES TO
THE FAMILIES OF SOME SANDY HOOK
VICTIMS AND AN FBI AGENT WHO
RESPONDED TO THE SCHOOL
MASSACRE.
THIS STEMS FROM A JUDGE FINDING
JONES AND HIS COMPANY LIABLE FOR
DEFAMING THE FAMILIES THROUGH
HIS FALSE STATEMENTS IN THE
WEEKS AND MONTHS AFTER 20 FIRST
GRADERS AND TEACHERS WERE
KILLED.
AN ATTORNEY HIRED BY JONES TO
TESTIFY FOR FREE SPEECH SYSTEMS,
GAVE HOURS OF TESTIMONY ON
MONDAY ABOUT JONES' INFOWAR
SHOW.
IF HE READS IT, HE'LL BROADCAST
IT ELSEWHERE.
HE DOESN'T DO ANY INDEPENDENT
ANALYSIS OF WHAT HE'S READING.
>> DO YOU RECALL THE COMMENT HE
MADE WHERE HE SAID I DID DEEP
RESEARCH AND IT JUST PRETTY MUCH
DIDN'T HAPPEN, RIGHT?
>> ESSENTIALLY THAT'S WHAT THE
QUOTE IS.
>> AND THAT'S WHAT HE WANTED HIS
AUDIENCE TO BELIEVE, RIGHT?
>> THAT'S WHAT HE SAID ON THAT
PARTICULAR OCCASION.
>> SHE ADMITTED ON THE STAND
THAT FALSE STATEMENTS WERE MADE
ABOUT THE SANDY HOOK SHOOTING.
>> I DON'T THINK THAT WE
DISAGREE THAT THERE WERE FALSE
STATEMENTS MADE IN CONNECTION
WITH THE SANDY HOOK
LITIGATION -- NOT LITIGATION,
SORRY, BUT IN CONNECTION WITH
SANDY HOOK.
>> AND ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
FREE SPEECH DOESN'T DISAGREE
WITH, IS THE TITLE OF THE VIDEO,
CONNECTICUT SCHOOL MASSACRE
LOOKS LIKE FALSE FLAG, WITNESSES
SAY IS FALSE.
>> I DON'T DISAGREE WITH THAT,
NO.
>> JONES HAS MADE A FORTUNE OFF
MERCHANDISE AND SALES OF
SUPPLEMENTS.
ATTORNEYS FOR THE PLAINTIFFS
TRIED TO PROVE JONES KNOWS THE
MORE TRAFFIC HIS VIDEOS GET ON
LINE, THE MORE SALES FOR HIS
COMPANY.
>> HE KNOWS WHAT HE'S TALKING
ABOUT TRANSLATES TO SALES, YES.
>> THEY ALSO SHOWED ANALYTICS
FROM JONES' SITE THAT ONLINE
SALES SKYROCKETED FOLLOWING THE
DECEMBER 2012 SANDY HOOK
SHOOTING.
>> TO 6.3 MILLION USERS,
CORRECT?
>> THAT'S WHAT IT SAYS.
>> GOES FROM 29.5 PAID USERS TO
37 MILLION PAID USERS, CORRECT?
>> THAT'S WHAT IT SAYS, YES.
>> YOU KNOW FROM DECEMBER
THROUGH THE END OF JANUARY, ALEX
JONES AND FREE SPEECH SYSTEMS
WERE PUBLISHING CLAIMS THAT THE
SHOOTING WAS STAGED, CORRECT?
>> I BELIEVE SO, YES.
>> WE'VE ALSO HEARD FROM AN FBI
AGENT, FAMILY MEMBERS TALKING
ABOUT HOW FOR THE PAST TEN YEARS
THEY FELT LTHEIR LIVES WERE IN
DANGER BECAUSE OF THE LIES THAT
JONES SPREAD.
HE HASN'T BEEN IN THE COURTROOM
BUT HE IS EXPECTED TO TESTIFY IN
HIS DEFENSE, HE DID LAST MONTH
WHERE A TEXAS JURY AWARDED ONE
FAMILY NEARLY 50 MILLION IN
DAMAGES.
THIS TRIAL IS EXPECTED TO LAST
SEVERAL WEEKS AND WE'RE WATCHING
IT CLOSELY.
>> WE CERTAINLY ARE, THANK YOU
FOR THAT REPORT.